gases lacrimógenos palos e incluso
perdigones la protesta que inició de
forma pacífica en Lima Perú derivó en
fuertes enfrentamientos entre las
fuerzas de seguridad y los manifestantes
los casi 7.000 uniformados desplegados
en el centro de la capital reprimieron
con violencia a los miles de congregados
las organizaciones denuncian incluso
agresiones contra la prensa
fotoperiodista Sebastián Castañeda de
router si Ernesto Benavides de afp
resultaron con heridas por disparo de
perdigón durante cobertura de protesta
desde ant periodistas exigimos el cese
de represión policial y garantías al
trabajo periodístico y derecho a la
protesta el mismo día que la presidenta
Dina boluarte declaró su pedido a una
tregua nacional para establecer una mesa
de diálogo y rechazó su dimisión el
principal reclamo de los peruanos en las
calles alegando que las protestas son
acusadas por grupos radicales la
respuesta de las autoridades peruanas al
estallido social volvió a dejar decenas
de heridos eso es una acción
violento generado por un grupo
de personas
radicales que tienen como agenda agenda
política y económica algunos medios de
comunicación locales e independientes
informaron también de nuevas detenciones
reportando un menor de edad herido
cuando la policía intentaba dispersar la
multitudinaria marcha estábamos viniendo
por toda esta Avenida de manera pacífica
y de repente esta policía mira todo
diseñada todo organizada para poder
bloquearnos creen que somos bandas
asesinos terroristas No señores aquí
nosotros marchamos de manera pacífica el
martes los bloqueos también se dieron en
el sur del país que ha puesto la mayoría
de los muertos de las últimas semanas y
Es que desde que iniciaron las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales se
han registrado al menos 60 fallecidos y
miles de heridos